[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an italian fantasy superhero
film called the invisible boy
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
at the beginning of the movie we see a
boy named michaele celensi cycling to
his school in trieste italy he has a 50
euro note with which he plans to buy a
costume for a party at school he sits
behind his longtime crush stella their
class is interrupted by a police officer
named giovanna who also happens to be
michaela's mother she is there to
inquire about a student's disappearance
jovana requests the class to inform the
police if they hear from the missing
student
after she leaves michaela's nose starts
to bleed so he runs to the bathroom his
bullies who have been troubling him for
a long time threaten him into handing
them all of his money he goes back home
disheartened by the incident he brings
out a few pennies he had saved and
decides to buy one with the money
michaele then visits a rusty looking
store and asks for a superhero costume
the shopkeeper hands him a skin-tight
overall and a lousy cape he claims that
it is the suit of a chinese superhero
michaele doesn't seem fond of the
costume but buys it anyway when giovanna
returns home from work she sees michaela
in his costume refusing to go to the
party because he thinks he looks stupid
she reassures him that he looks good and
sends him to the party there michaela
enjoys himself and even talks to his
crush stella but then his bullies play a
video of stella walking through the
street they claim that the video was
found on michaela's phone and that he
has been stalking stella an embarrassed
mikaele runs to the bathroom and locks
himself in all of his classmates bang on
the door from outside asking him to open
it michaela is frustrated and wishes
that he was invisible right before the
lights go out in the following scene we
see him jump out of the bathroom window
and go back home the next morning
michaela wakes up to his dog barking at
him he doesn't pay him much attention
and goes to the bathroom to brush his
teeth when he looks into the mirror
michaela is beyond shocked to see just
his robe in the brush his body is
invisible in the mirror michaela rushes
out and takes his robe off just then his
mother walks in and completely ignores
the boy proving that only michaela can
see himself when she starts looking
around michaela quickly writes that he
has gone to school early on a piece of
paper and places it on the bed giovanna
reads it and dismisses the matter after
leaving the room she calls michaela on
his phone an invisible michaele picks it
up and tells her that he is fine
confused about what he should do next he
dresses up in long-sleeved clothes after
covering every part of his body he goes
to school and watches stella from afar
michaela then notices his bully and
plans to teach him a lesson for
troubling him so much he takes his
clothes off and walks inside the school
naked and invisible during class he
picks up the bully's paintball gun and
uses it on the teacher causing the
teacher to suspend the bully
then michaela makes his way to the girls
changing room and watches them undress
well that didn't take him long
suddenly a towel lands on him making his
silhouette evident to everyone right
then his powers start to fade making him
visible again the girls scream as they
see a naked mikalei under the towel the
next day michaela is in his class where
a psychologist named basili is giving a
lecture about teen's mental health two
of michaela's classmates have run away
from home in the past month so he thinks
it is necessary to understand teen's way
of thinking as michaela listens to the
lecture his hands start to glow and
suddenly they disappear thankfully the
class is over and he runs out before
anyone can see him disappear he rushes
home covering all parts of his body and
sees his little sister candela in his
room michaela asks her to go downstairs
while facing the wall a suspicious
candela opens and closes the door to
make it seem like she is left michaela
doesn't turn around to check and starts
to take his clothes off when he turns
around candela screams in fear seeing
her brother is invisible michaela calms
her down and tells her that his costume
has given him superpowers
meanwhile at the police station the
psychiatrist basili works with giovanna
to investigate the missing children
giovanna insists that the children might
be kidnapped but basili argues that they
are just being rebellious which is
normal for their age when giovanna
returns home michaela is still invisible
giovanna talks to someone on the phone
revealing that michaela is adopted a
surprised and hurt michaele walks out of
the house to a nearby swing while he is
swinging stella arrives there and thinks
michaela is a ghost
she doesn't seem to be scared and
instead asks him to be her friend he
makes a smiling face on the sand to
communicate with her the two decide to
meet again
after stella leaves michaela sees a man
nearby staring at him even though he is
invisible the man walks away using a
stick revealing that he is blind
at night michaela visits stella's home
stella is delighted to have made an
invisible friend the two kiss but right
then michaela's powers start to fade he
runs away before stella can see his face
later stella is in her gymnastic class
alone when a needle strikes her back it
makes her drop unconscious
elsewhere michaela has decided to tell
stella about him being the invisible boy
he makes his way to her gymnastic class
with his dog when he reaches the
building he sees a masked man carrying
stella michaelia attacks the man and the
dog bites his hand however the man
manages to escape with the girl
later the police arrive at the scene
they figure that the missing children
weren't running away but have been
kidnapped stella wakes up in a strange
facility with her head attached to
several wires the psychiatrist basili is
there interrogating her it turns out
that he is the one who has been
kidnapping the children they run some
tests on the girl and send her to a cell
two of her friends who had gone missing
before her are there too the following
day michael is alone at a nearby beach
when suddenly the blind man from the
previous day appears in front of him the
man answers all of michaela's questions
before he can ask them it is as if he
can read minds when michaela asks him
who he is the man reveals that his name
is andrej and he is michaela's father
the boy doesn't believe andrej and
accuses him of lying andrage then begins
to tell his story he used to be a normal
man from a small town in russia until a
devastating nuclear explosion hit the
town the radiation killed a lot of
people and made a permanent change in
others it caused their dna to mutate
giving them unique superhuman abilities
like flying telepathy being invisible
and so on these people were called the
specials and were brought to a military
camp called the division to be used as
weapons the division used them beyond
their capacity the more power the
specials used the weaker they got
another side effect was that everyone
was infertile except for andrage and
michaela's mother the two gave birth to
michaela who was the first special kid
but as soon as he was born they took him
away
so the parents decided to run away with
michaela and were successful but the
people from the division weren't going
to back down they pursued the couple to
bring the child back michaela's father
had the power to read people's minds
while his mother had the power to be
invisible andrej managed to run away
with michael but his wife was killed by
the division andres knew mikayla wasn't
safe with him so he put him in front of
giovanna's door after reading her mind
and confirming she was a good person now
the people of the division have found
out that the special kid lives in the
town so they are kidnapping children and
testing them to see if they are special
after listening to his true origin
michaela is shocked he almost doesn't
believe it but andrej says that they do
not have time to talk because the
fisherman beside them thinks andris is
suspicious and has called the police
andrej hands michaela suit that turns
invisible along with his body he then
removes the fisherman's memory and
leaves
the police arrive shortly along with
basili giovanna reveals to him that
michaela is adopted which makes basili
believe that he might be this special
kid he offers to take mikaela home when
they reach home michaela notices
basili's hand injury which is the exact
place his dog had bitten stella's
kidnapper he looks at the man
suspiciously and tries to run away but
it turns out that basili has locked all
the doors and is planning to abduct him
michaela runs into a room and takes off
his clothes turning invisible he manages
to escape while basili follows him when
they are on the streets michaela sees
his bully ivan on his bike he sits
behind him and asks him to drive away
quickly a nervous ivan obliges when they
reach a safe area michaela reveals
himself to ivan and tells him about
their classmates abduction
meanwhile stella and her friends see
ventilation on the ceiling they climb on
each other and stella manages to step
outside while hiding from guards she
climbs a tower and reaches a searching
light believing that her invisible
friend is looking for her she makes a
smiling face on the light and flashes it
up to the sky
michaela sees the smiling face and
realizes that stella is trying to hint
at them he and ivan follow the light but
as soon as they get there stella is
caught by the guards ivan causes an
electrical malfunction using his
paintball gun as an invisible mikalei
goes inside he sees basili and his men
monitoring giovanna and andrej who have
joined hands to look from a chele he
then goes further in and knocks out a
guard using his gun he threatens the
other guard to open the cell where
stella and the others are trapped after
getting them out and trapping the guards
inside michaela reveals himself to his
friends who are beyond surprised
the boys want to run away but stella
insists that they save an old man who
she has seen locked in another room she
and michaela go to save the man but
stella takes him to the villains instead
and points a gun at michaela she
suddenly falls unconscious and the old
man behind her starts talking it turns
out that he has the power of mind
control he has been controlling basili
and stella to get michaela here he then
brings down a submarine and puts
michaela and stella in it the men take
the two into the sea
just then andres and giovanna arrive at
the place and meet ivan the building has
been set to explode in a few seconds
they quickly save the two abducted kids
and basili from inside andres reads
basili's mind and realizes that someone
was controlling them they quickly get
away from the building which explodes
into pieces right after
back in the submarine michaeli discovers
his telekinesis power and starts
trashing the place
using his powers he manages to kill the
man and save himself and stella they
finally get back to the shore where a
lot of people are waiting for them
michaela goes invisible in front of them
flaunting his power andrage tells
michaela that they will have to remove
everyone's memories because the division
will come looking for them again
michaela obliges and kisses stella for
the last time
andres tells michaela he will be back
and leaves after erasing everyone's
memories everyone then returns to their
normal life
the scene cuts to somewhere in russia
michaela's mother who is thought to be
dead was only wounded in the encounter
she has defeated the division back then
and is now ruling it in fact she was the
one who sent those people to get
michaela back to her the woman is now
against all the normal people who look
at them as if they are freaks at last a
guard informs her that although they
lost michaela they have found his twin
sister natasha a clip of the past shows
us that andres ran away with two
children that day the movie ends as the
guard tells michaela's mother that
natasha is somewhere in morocco hinting
towards a sequel
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching